طويل
الناقبين وهنا لك بيان قويه
سافرت هذا الاسبوع وكان اجليا مدى قرب
العالم وحلفائنا ومنافسين ايضا تابعوا
انتخاباتنا في امريكا
في امريكا لحمايه والدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
الان يسمحوا لي ان نتحدث بشكل موجزه عن
جدول اعمال الماضيه في مصر
وكمبوديا وهنا في اندونيسيا في هذه
اللحظات اللي تواجهم فيها العالم تحديات
كبيره من التضخم وهزمه المناخي الى حرب
روسيا الدمويه ضد اوكرانيا نحن نجمعهم
اكبر تحالف من الشركه لتحقيق النتائج في
قيمه المناخ 27 في مصر
بتاعكم
الاول لمعالجه ازمه المناخ وازمه الطاقه
في امريكا والعالم فالولايات المتحده
ستلبي وتفي باهدافنا اتفاق باريس وسوف
نستمر بالعامل مع شركائنا لدعم الدول
الفقيره
لمواهمه طموحات العالميه مع اهداف الدرجه
والنصف من الحراره مع الانتقالي الى طاقه
نظيفه وفي قمه السيان الشرقي اسيا التزمت
بالعمل
والهندي نظام اني ما هو ضروري هذه المنطقه
وهو
الاماني والازدهار
وحلفائنا من استراليا واليابان وجمهوريه
كوريا وتحديث ازماتنا وتعويق مشاركتنا مع
شركائنا وتعزيز التعاون بين حلفائنا
لمواجهه التهديدات المشتركه لتحقيق امننا
وامنهم من ضمنها كوريا الشماليه
ونلتقيت شخصيا مع سجن بنك
نوفا
وصريحا حول نوايانا
واولوياتنا وكان جليا هو كان واضح وانا
ايضا اننا سندافع عن المصالح الامريكيه
وقيامها وترويج حقوق الانسان العالميه
والوقوفي والامتثال لقانون الدولي والعمل
مع 10 كانوا حلفائنا سوف نتنافس بشده
ولكنني لا ابحث عن
بالاداره هذا التنافس بشكل مسؤول اود ان
اتاكد من كل دوله تلتزم
بالقوانين الدوليه ناقشنا ذلك
السياسه الصين الواحده لم تتغير لم تتغير
اللي يبقى الوضع الراهنه لتحقيق الالتزام
والاستقرار وان كان واضح ايضا الولايات
المتحده والصيني عليهما العمله حيث امكن
لحل التحديات العالميه التي طالبوا كل
دوله وهما جهدها وانا دي عروسه اوكرانيا
واكدنا ايمان المشتركه ولا التهديد
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه غير مقبول
والطلبت من الوزير لكن السفر الى صيني
متابعه محادثاتنا والاستمرار بابقاء خطط
الاتصال مفتوحه بين بلدين مستقبل في جمعته
مجموعه 20 يوم غد سوف نتحدث المسائل
الهامه لحياه البشر ليست فقط هنا بل كذلك
حلفائنا وشركائنا وهذا يعني معالجتها
يتسببت بها الاعتداء فقط في اوكرانيا
بالشعوب العالم خاصه ثم يخص الامن الغذائي
وتعزيزي اساسيات الاقتصاد العالمي للجميع
والدعم لغادتي
والاستثمارات لتعزيز الامن الصحي العالمي
وجعله هذا العالم مستخدم بشكل افضل جائع
القادمه مجموعه ال20 كانت منتدى اكبر
اقتصادات العالم للعمل
لمصلحه الشعوب في كل مكان وتطلع
الاجتماعاتنا يوم غد اسمحوا لي ان اختم
بالتالي في اول سفره لانها عبر البحار في
العام الماضي قلت بان امريكا عادت عادت
سواء في ديارنا وعلى طاقه محدثات ولقيادته
العالم وخلال عام نصف لتبعتها اظهرنا
تماما ما هو معنى ذلك يكتفي بالتزاماتها
وتستثمر في قوتنا في بلادنا وتعمل الى
جانب حلفائنا وشركائنا لتحقيق التقدم
الحقيقي حول العالم وفي هذه اللحظات
الحاسمه لا امه موقفها افضل مساعده بناء
المستقبل بنار به اكثر من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يسار الاجابه عن
اسئلتكم وقليل هنالك اربعه اسئله ولكن لن
يجيب عن 10 اسئله من كل شخص اذا فقط اربعه
اشخاص يطرحون الاسئله سؤال واحد للجميع
كان خامس
من قال في بدايه يوم الثلاثاء اجتماعات
انكم
تحاول التنافس الى صراعات وفقا للجماعات
اليوم هل تؤمنون بان حرب بارده جديده مع
الصين يمكن تجنبها وخاصه
تايوان تحدثتم عن النوايا هل تصدقون
وتؤمنون بالصيني
ذلك
الجزء الاول انا امن وحقنا انه لا يجب ان
يكون هناك حرب بارده التقيت عده مراتب
رئيس
وكنا صريحين مع بعضنا البعض في كافه
المسائل ولا اعتقد ان هنالك اي محاوله
وشيكه من قبل الصين
للغازته بان سياستنا في تايوان لم تتغير
اطلاقا هي نفس السياسه ونفس الموق او
اوضحتم باننا نريد ان تحلل مشاكل عبر
المضيقي بشكل سلمي ولا يجب ان تصل الى هذه
المرحله وانا مقتنع من انه فهم تماما ما
قلته وانا فهمته ايضا
واعتقد ان الولايات المتحده مستعده اكثر
من اي دوله اخرى في العالم اقتصاديا
وسياسيا للتعامل مع الظروف المتغيره حول
العالم
اتفقنا باننا
سنضع واقل الظروف الخاصه حول بعض المسائل
التي
اتفقنا على ان
يكون لدينا الاعضاء الاداره المناسبين